[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anyways
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
please
please
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
please
oh
please be seated
[Music]
at this time i wish to as archbishop
extend
the condolences my own personal
condolences
but also the condolences of the entire
catholic community
for your husband for your dad
and for your son
in situations like this it is difficult
and challenging and we have seen
way too many of them in colorado
and yet we have trust and confidence
in our god
eric was a man who gave his life
and jesus has told us greater love than
this
no man has than to lay down his life
eric lived that
just in the testimonies that i have seen
of his life
testimonies from other officers
it was evident that he was a man of god
one who put christ first in his life
put his family first
and put the community and saving others
and so you have my deepest condolences
know that you are in my prayers and in
my thoughts
and also to the police officers who are
here
know too that you are in my prayers
eric has shown what is best
about the service you give
to our community to our cities
and to our country
and as police officers i want to honor
you
for too often you are taken for granted
and yet in situations like this
you are the ones who protect human life
you know better than any of us
that what eric did
was something that
you place yourselves in every day
and you save lives
and so i pray today for your protection
i pray today in gratitude
for the witness that you give as
officers
may our lord continue to comfort
you eric talley's family in the days
ahead know that he is in the hands of
the father
that he has returned to god
[Laughter]
so
dude
you would think that the evil which was
done
in boulder monday last would break the
heart of god
and it did we must consider
given that many wonder where god was
monday last
we must consider this and the answer is
first
he was in the garden of gethsemane
the 1998th anniversary of that event
happens this coming thursday
and saint john henry newman writes about
it as
clearly as any i know
he said here then in that most awful
hour
knelt the savior of the world putting
off the defenses of his divinity
dismissing his reluctant angels who in
myriads were ready at his call
and opening his arms bearing his breast
sinless as he was to the assault of his
foe
a foe whose breath was a pestilence and
whose embrace
was an agony there he knelt
motionless and still while the vile and
horrible fiend clad his spirit in a robe
steeped in all that is hateful and
heinous in human crime
which clung close around his heart
and filled his conscience and found its
way
to every sense and pour of his mind
and spread over him like a moral
leprosy until he almost felt himself to
be
that which he could never be and which
his foe
would feign have made him are these
the hands of the immaculate lamb of god
once innocent
but now read with ten thousand barbarous
deeds of blood
are these his lips not uttering prayer
and praise and holy blessings
but as if defiled with oaths and
blasphemies
and doctrines of devils or his eyes
profaned as they are by all the evil
visions and idolatrous fascinations
for which men have abandoned their
adorable creator
and his ears they ring with sounds of
revelry and strife
his heart is frozen with avarice and
cruelty and unbelief
and his very memory is laden with every
sin
that has been committed since the fall
and adversaries such as these gather
round the blessed lord in millions
now they come in troops more numerous
than the locust or the palmer worm or
the plagues of hail
flies and frogs which were sent against
pharaoh
of the living and of the dead and of the
as yet
unborn of the lost and the saved of thy
people
of strangers of sinners and saints
all sins are there they dearest are
there
thy saints and thy chosen are upon thee
thy three apostles peter james and john
but not as comforters but as accusers
like the friends of job
sprinkling dust towards heaven and
keeping curses on my head
all are there but one
one only is not there one only
for she who had no part in sin
she only could console thee and
therefore she is not nigh
she will be near thee on the cross she
is separated from thee
in the garden she has been thy companion
and they confident
throughout thy life she interchanged
with thee the pure thoughts and holy
meditations
of thirty years but her virgin ear may
not take in
nor may her immaculate heart conceive
what is now
envisioned before thee none
was equal to the weight but god
the mother of god for all her sanctity
nay
by reason of it could not have borne
even one
brood of that innumerable progeny of
satan
which now compasses thee about
it is the long history of a world
and god alone can bear the load of it
hopes blighted vows broken lights
quenched warnings scorned
opportunities lost the innocent betrayed
the young hardened the penitent
relapsing
the just overcome the aged feeling the
false sophistry of misbelief
the willfulness of passion the obveracy
of pride the tyranny of habit
the canker of remorse the wasting fever
of care the anguish of shame
the pining of disappointment the
sickness of despair
such cruel such pitiable spectacles such
heart-rending
revolting detestable maddening scenes
nay the haggard faces the convulsed lips
the flushed
cheek the dark brow of the willing
slaves of evil
they are all before him now they are
upon him
they are in him they are with him
instead
of that ineffable peace which has
inhabited his soul since the moment of
his conception
they are upon him and they are all
but his own he cries
to his father as if he were the criminal
not the victim his agony takes the form
of guilt and
compunction he is doing
penance he is making confession
he is exercising contrition with a
reality
and a virtue infinitely greater than
that of
all the saints and penitents together
for he
is the one victim for us all the sole
satisfaction the real penitent
all but the real sinner
he saw everything that happened in
boulder
and then did penance for it in his trial
his crowning of thorns
his scourging at the pither the carrying
of his cross and ultimately
in the crucifixion that is where god was
last monday you and i are here for
several purposes
the first purpose of the requiem mass is
that of every other mass
to give to god the worship that is due
to him which is possible only through
christ our lord
as it is stated in the catechism of the
catholic church
the sacrifice of christ and the
sacrifice of the eucharist
are one single sacrifice the victim
is one and the same the same now offers
through the ministry of priests then
offered him
on the cross only the manner of offering
is different and since this divine
sacrifice which is celebrated in the
mass
the same christ who offered himself
one's flooding
on the altar of the cross is contained
in offered in an unbloody manner
and this sacrifice is truly propitiatory
the second purpose we are here today is
to thank
god the father for having created eric
what a creation he was he was a good man
an honorable and faithful father a
faithful husband a son a friend
a faithful and heroic officer of the law
but i will stop there since traditional
catholics do not want to be canonized at
their funerals
they want prayers for their stay in
purgatory they want prayers for their
loved ones
whom they left behind
the third purpose of this mass is to
thank god the son for redeeming eric
what he did for eric he did for all
yes even for his enemies
none of us can justify ourselves before
god
and if we receive sacramental absolution
it is only because god the holy ghost
takes the sacrifice of christ
and joins it with our efforts to improve
to become good
this is sanctification
and this is our fourth purpose here to
thank god the holy ghost for having
sanctified eric
in the sacraments this thank gives
thanksgiving has shown in many ways
such as those in attendance here we are
deeply grateful for the presence of our
archbishop
we are deeply grateful for the
outpouring of support for mrs talley and
her family
we are profoundly grateful to all the
officers of the law
many of whom who have traveled a long
way to be here
we thank the boulder police chief harold
others from officer talley's boulder
police department
we thank representative valdez who is
here
the staff at the cathedral basilica
father cathane director of the cathedral
who
immediately agreed when we asked
permission from my parish
to have the requiem here at the basilica
there's so many to things such as the
colorado fallen heroes foundation
and all the law enforcement agencies
from around the state
which had done so magnificently to
support the family throughout
the last week
when our blessed savior died on golgotha
a roman centurion who was there
said truly this man was the son of god
he was right but we want to say to the
centurion
do something his mother is right over
there she's already lost her husband
and now she's lost her only begotten son
so don't just stand there
go back to the barracks take up a
collection
this has been done in many ways by the
police fallen heroes our parish
by so many coming in from all over
and who knows but that some politicians
will show some common sense
and move to increase funding for the
police
and perhaps even more sense will be
shown by efforts to restore
christian culture to our country writing
more and more laws
will not be sufficient but in the
meantime today we give thanks to god for
eric's life by celebrating a right of
mass
which eric loved he loved this mass
the ancient roman rite gives
thanksgiving to god for eric
gives comfort to his loved ones makes
reparation for evil
and sanctifies us if we let it and it
does so
by several means first by reverence
reverence is a word from the latin
language riverior
it's a deponent verb means something you
do
and something that happens to you
and it is one of the several words in
latin for fear
the holy eucharist the altar the missile
the crucifix eric's morphle remains
all of these things are given the utmost
reverence at the heart of which
is fear of harming someone or something
that we love
so we pray the utmost human respect
to the mortal remains of eric talley not
just because he died a hero
but because his body was a temple of the
holy ghost by virtue
of his baptism second by emphasizing the
doctrine that the soul once created by
god
is not destroyed but changed in the
preface of the mass which father will
sing
here's the line vita
life is changed not ended
and this is represented by the candles
they're different the ones around eric's
body and the ones on the altar
the ones on the altar of a bleached wax
they represent you and i the living
and they represent were bleached so to
speak we do not appear to others as we
truly
are but the candles around
eric's coffin are unbleached wax
symbolizing
that he has now gone to god just as he
was created
just as he is
unbleached and it's almost as if the
flame coming from those candles is
slightly different than the ones on the
altar
life has changed not ended
third by wearing black the traditional
jewish and western color of death
and this is in contrast of course to the
age we live in which often seeks to
repress the cardinal emotion of sadness
if someone has said many in our times
feel driven to cheer them up
and not let them be sad but before
jerusalem was destroyed christ wept
and he went to the coming misfortune of
his enemies
and he wept at the death of his friend
lazarus
there is a time to mourn a time to weep
yet as saint paul says not as the pagans
do
but as those who have hope
fourth by praying for the repose of
eric's soul
this ancient tradition so well
exemplified by the maccabees and the
sacrifice they had
ensured in the temple for their fallen
comrades
is carried on here today in this
basilica
and this practice of praying for the
dead assumes
that there is a purgatory dr samuel
johnson a famous protestant man of
letters was asked by his biographer
james boswell about the subject of
purgatory
their short exchange went like this
boswell
what do you think sir of purgatory as
believed by the roman catholics
johnson why spirit is a very harmless
doctrine
they are of the opinion that the
generality of mankind
are neither so obstinately wicked as to
deserve everlasting punishment
nor are they so good as to merit being
admitted immediately into the society of
blessed spirits
and therefore god is graciously pleased
to allow of a middle state
where they may be purified by certain
degrees of suffering
you see sir there is nothing
unreasonable in this
boswell but then sir their masses for
the dead
johnson why sir if it once be
established that there are souls in
purgatory
it is as proper to pray for them as for
our brethren
the rest of our brethren of mankind who
are yet
in this life lastly
the traditional latin requiem does not
judge
it does not say in the texts or the
sermon that eric was a saint
or saintly or in heaven it does not say
in the text of the sermon that he was
bad or evil in hell
it says simply he was a human being
affected by original sin
in need of salvation and was offered
salvation by christ
we cannot know if he received that
salvation
although there are many many signs that
he did
and the greatest of those perhaps is how
he died
since then we do not have the pride to
judge where he is
we behave with solemnity because as the
archbishop said he is now in the hands
of god
god is the only one